all right welcome to class everyone okay
so this is our second lecture on partial
differential equations and today we're
going to derive the one the heat
equation and solve it for some limited
conditions
okay the 1d heat equation and this is
really going to start setting the frame
for some of the advanced stuff that
we're gonna learn next week and the week
after and for the next four or five
weeks so we're going to start thinking
about Fourier analysis Laplace
transforms and the solution of spatial
differential equations so I found this
book in a dumpster it's called the
analytical theory of heat any guesses
who wrote this book was written a long
time ago let's see when it was written I
found in a dumpster last year okay it
was written 200 some years ago not
Newton not Euler not applause good
guesses all of them not Maxwell Fourier
okay so Fourier wrote his original works
on heat transfer it's part of the reason
he developed Fourier transforms in the
first place extremely powerful theory in
his preliminary discourse is actually
one of the few books written in that
time that's actually readable it's very
well written it's still readable today
and he has about ten pages or 20 pages
just discussing why he transports
importance he talks about climate change
the seasons all kinds of interesting
things that we still care about and he
says heat light gravity penetrates every
substance of the universe it's rays
occupy all parts of space the object of
our work is to set forth the
mathematical laws which this element
obeys the theory of heat will hereafter
form one of the most important branches
of
physics and that's certainly true so
we're gonna start with the simplest 1d
heat equation and we're gonna build up
from there and we're going to use this
to motivate the tools that were
developed by people like Fourier like
Laplace to actually solve these PDE s
that we still use today okay now there's
three steps in dealing with a partial
differential equation the first step is
deriving the PDE and essentially this
means that we're codifying some kind of
physical intuition or some kind of
observations that we have about a system
into a mathematical form next we want to
solve the PDE and hopefully if we're
really good then we can understand the
solution and interpret our results so we
gain some kind of interpretation okay so
this is generally what I mean when I say
that we're gonna learn about PDE s it
doesn't just mean we're going to learn
how to solve them we're also going to
learn how to code up physics into a PDE
and how to interpret the solution of a
PDE in terms of building our physical
intuition otherwise they'd be pretty
pointless to just learn how to solve an
equation pointless but interesting okay
so the 1d heat equation we're going to
consider the temperature distribution in
a thin rod probably of something like
metal okay so consider the temperature
distribution and we're gonna call this
some function U and that function
depends on both space and time so it's
spatially varying and it's evolving in
time in a thin metal rod and I'm saying
thin because I want to be able to assume
that this thing is basically 1d and I
don't have to worry about cross-sections
or 2d effects or anything like that okay
so I have this thin piece of metal
and let's say that it goes from length
yeah x equals zero to x equals big L so
the length of this rod is L and let's
assume that I have some temperature
distribution on this rod so at every
point X there's a temperature which I'm
just graphically depicting as the height
of this red curve U of X and T okay
pretty straightforward so far so all
we've done is just drawn a picture and
so what we're gonna do is we're gonna
take the common sense kind of physics of
how heat is transferred in a material
and we're going to start using that to
build up an equation so this is almost
always the first part is you have some
kind of a conservation law like
conservation of energy conservation of
mass or momentum you know the first or
second laws of thermodynamics are what
we're going to use and so the basic idea
is to write down a phrase in words that
describes how the physical system
evolves and then try to code that up
into math okay so the words are okay so
we're interested in how this temperature
distribution changes in time and in
space so we're interested in things like
rates of change of this temperature in
time and rates of change of the
temperature in space so the rate of
change of heat energy and this is a rate
of change of heat energy in time and
this is also at every point X so at any
point X the rate of change of heat
energy in a little section in time is
equal to what well how can my heat
energy in a little segment
change in time what can what can cause
my heat energy a little piece of metal
to change first of all what is heat
energy in the first place what does heat
energy actually mean yeah molecular
kinetic energy right vibrations so these
things are moving around with some
molecular kinetic energy and they bump
into each other and they transfer their
molecular kinetic energy and what do we
call that we can call it like thermal
diffusion or heat flux okay so this is
the rate of change of heat energy in
time at any given point X is the heat
flow through the boundaries kind of if
you drew a box around that point so the
heat flow or heat flux just a fancy word
for flow through the boundaries and this
is again at some point X and what else
can cause the heat to change in this rod
think really really simple sorry heat
generation whether this rod was on fire
okay so essentially heat generation heat
sources so for example I'm sure most of
you know about the thermite reaction
which is one of my favorite of all
chemical reactions because you can
basically make it well I'm not gonna
tell you how to make it but it's
relatively easy to make and it has its
own fuel and its own oxidizer so you
can't put it out it burns extremely hot
it'll burn right through solid metal but
you could basically model it out as its
it is itself basically a metal but it
actually has heat generation because
there's chemistry going on okay so the
system itself might have some chemistry
that's causing
heat generation at different locations
along this Robin but for most of what
we're gonna do we're gonna assume that
that's zero because it's a little
complicated
okay so let's code this up into math how
do i quantify heat energy in terms of
temperature what are the things that
matter for heat energy in some material
okay specific heat what's specific heat
right it's how much energy I have to add
to raise the temperature of something by
like one degree per mass something like
that right so I have the specific heat C
of X now I'm saying that it actually
might vary as a function of X this might
not be a uniform material so I have my
specific heat I also need to know what
the density this is if I have more mass
or less mass all right so I need to know
the density and I of course need my
temperature X and T this is my
temperature and this quantity here is my
heat energy okay so this whole thing is
my heat energy but what do I need on the
left-hand side of this equation it's not
just heat energy it's the time rate of
change of heat energy okay so what I
really have is D DT or partial with
respect to time
my heat energy equals what well it
equals heat flux through my boundaries
plus heat generation I'm just gonna
write it down and then I'll show you
where these terms come from so there's
something minus partial Q partial X I
have not told you what Q is yet plus
this a big Q of X in time so I'm just
defining any heat that's generated along
the length of this at any point in time
is given by this function big queue
usually we're going to call this zero
and I'm saying that this is my heat flux
term okay so I need to explain to you
how I got this heat flux term what it
means but did this basic idea make sense
I have you know some material some
physical system if I draw a box around
this then I have to have some
conservation happening I have to have
you know conservation of heat energy so
the rate of change of heat energy is
equal to heat energy that's either lost
or gained through the boundaries plus
any heat generation through you know
chemical reactions or anything like that
this could also be heat loss due to
radiation that's also totally valid okay
so I need to explain this heat flux term
so so to explain the partial Q partial X
term I'm going to draw a picture we're
going to zoom into a tiny little section
of this rod okay
so this is a little section of the rod
from X to X plus Delta X and what I'm
doing is I'm defining this function Q
which is just the heat flux through this
little surface area okay so let me make
a note that the outside surface is
insulated so I'm making this is a
fundamental assumption that we usually
make in this problem it's a silly
assumption and we're gonna break it in
about 15 minutes but we're going to
assume for now that our steel rod has an
insulating sheath around it so it can
only conduct heat to its neighboring
pieces of the metal rod and maybe
through the end pieces make sense we're
gonna insulate it so there's no heat
flux
out of the outer can part only through
the faces and so we define this function
Q Q of X and T is what do I call it I
call up the heat flux from left to right
okay so over here I call this the heat
flux through the boundaries and what I
really should call this is the heat
energy flux this is a very technically
subtle distinction I'm gonna explain why
it's the heat energy flux not just the
heat flux so the basic idea is that I
can have a heat flux from the little
piece of metal to the left of this swung
into it and I can have heat flux from
this little piece of metal to the piece
just to the right of it and I'm gonna
call this you know Q of X and Q of X
plus Delta X now if these are equal if Q
of X and Q of X plus Delta X are equal
what happens inside of here let's see
accounting did I gain or lose any heat
energy I didn't gain or lose any heat
energy so my heat energy change is given
by the heat flux as I take the limit as
Delta X goes to 0 of this quantity okay
so I'm really not interested in the raw
magnitude of heat flux you know into or
out of on the left side what I really
care about is what's the difference
what's the gradient of this heat flux
through this element so this is the
gradient partial Q partial X this is
what's going to tell me if the
temperature inside of this little box
goes up or goes down right if Q at X and
X plus Delta X are equal
then my temperature stays the same it
doesn't go up or down because I had no
heat energy and Entering but if I have a
gradient here then I am gonna have heat
energy entering and let's think about
the sign here let's say that Q of X plus
Delta X is bigger than Q of X what does
that mean so this gradient is positive
but it means that I have a net amount of
heat energy leaving which means my
temperature should go down okay so I
need a negative sign out here for my
negative heat energy flux and okay
good so this is my heat energy flux
meaning this is the term that has the
capacity of raising or lowering the
temperature in my segment the only way I
can raise or lower the temperature is to
have an increase in heat energy in this
location more thermal kinetic energy and
I get that not by having a large Q but
by harvan a large gradient in Q okay
meaning I'm pumping either in or out
energy the physics of the situation is
very interesting very important but it's
less interesting and important for this
class I'm not going to expect you to be
like an expert at all types of physics
but I do want to show you where these
terms come from and if they really are
like our ways of coding up physical
intuition okay so the last thing we need
to do is figure out how Q depends on
temperature okay
so the last thing we need is how it is
queue depend on temperature right
because I have this term in my equation
that doesn't have anything to do with
you and I really want a partial
differential equation in terms of my
temperature the change in temperature
with respect to time is some function of
my temperature okay how many of you can
tell me how the thermal heat flux
depends on temperature
all in this book by Fourier Fourier is
the one who discovered this and it bears
his name so it's called the Fourier law
of heat convection so Fourier made some
observations this is non-trivial I'm
basically taking like one of the
greatest physical discoveries and we're
trying to derive it here in class so
this is a little difficult it's supposed
to be this is not this is not all
obvious to me or it shouldn't be obvious
to you either so what are some
observations about how temperature
changes due to heat flux how does
temperature move in a in a solid so for
example if my rod had a uniform
temperature across the entire length
would there be any heat flux through it
okay so that's one observation so no
heat flux meaning little Q equals zero
when u equals a constant
Thanks okay what's another observation
how does heat flow if the temperature is
non-uniform yeah exactly
so heat flux is positive from higher to
lower higher to lower temperature and
what's the last observation about heat
flux when there's a temperature
different difference or temperature
gradients negative from lower to higher
but it is proportional to the
temperature difference so I get more
heat flux the hotter the bigger the
temperature difference is okay so heat
flux is proportional to Delta U okay so
Fourier took all of these observations
and he synthesized them into what's now
called boria's law of heat conduction
Fourier is law of heat conduction pretty
important and the basic idea is that
this function Q the heat flux is given
by the gradient of the temperature so Q
of X and T it's actually given by
negative constant times the gradient of
the temperature so if the temperature is
constant then it's equal to zero if the
temperature goes from lower to higher
then there's a negative heat flux so a
positive gradient means negative heat
flux that's what we expect if
temperature goes from higher to lower
then this is negative times
there's a positive heat flux and the
larger the gradient and the temperature
the larger the difference between
neighboring segments the more heat flux
there is and this is purely based now we
understand that this is based on you
know statistical thermodynamics you know
the vibration of individual particles
and quantum mechanics but at the time
this was based on course observations of
how fast things got colder okay so this
is a really important one okay and
finally we can bring that into this kind
of master equation and derive our heat
equation okay any questions about this
business of heat flux and being
proportional to the gradient of the
temperature and all this stuff basically
makes sense okay
we're talking about that conservation or
the rates of changes of heat energy okay
so I'm just gonna work above here okay
so what we have is let's say that our
specific heat and our density can in
fact change over the span of the rod but
they don't change any time kind of makes
sense like let's say that the metal
stays being a metal for ever for the
whole experiment then this time
derivative doesn't affect specific heat
it doesn't affect density it only
affects the temperature so I have C
times Rho times partial u partial T
equals and now I have this heat flux
term but I can plug in my new expression
for Q so this is equal to my negatives
cancel out and I just get constant times
the second partial derivative with
respect to U of U with respect to x
squared good
and I'm gonna keep this Q term around
for a little while but this is just kind
of just in case something crazy happens
like my medal catches fire okay much
simpler so we've gone from inwards what
we think the system is doing and some
observations of what we know happens for
hot and cold you know objects and we've
derived an equation that has to be true
if our assumption for true
and this is basically the general form
of the heat equation okay
okay any big questions at this point
what is this K mean what is the meaning
of K sorry good how easily the metal
transfers heat and what do we call that
thermal conductivity
okay so k is the thermal conductivity C
is the specific heat Rho is the density
you use the temperature these are all
real things with real units these are
not you know this equation is really
what's happening in this metal now I did
something a little funny here I've
allowed my specific heat and my density
to vary along space but I could also
allow K to vary along space in which
case this would really be a little more
complicated it would be partial partial
X of K of X partial u partial X right if
if this if the thermal conductivity
changed over the length of my metal then
I would actually have to do the chain
rule to get this term what are some
examples of thermal of metals whose
thermal conductivity would change over
the span or materials
sorry composites yeah composites would
make a lot of sense
maybe I have some material in a
centrifuge because I'm trying to
separate out some parts of the material
from other parts so I might have a
gradient of material properties okay
good so this is the basic idea of of
coating up kind of our physics into a
differential equation so there's a few
things I want to do I want to stop and
let you ask questions for a little while
and I also want to show how we can make
this system simpler and how we can make
it more complicated
and how we can solve it for a couple of
a couple of conditions okay so any
questions while I'm erasing at all
maybe I shouldn't be erasing while I'm
asking questions okay so we have a
differential equation and now it's time
to analyze this so first things first is
this equation linear or non-linear
a little complicated and my notes I say
it's nonlinear but it's not that
clear-cut these definitely change with
respect to X but they're not like
functions of U so that's not exactly
nonlinear in the normal sense what's
interesting is that a lot of materials
actually have a specific heat that is
temperature dependence this would be
very non linear if my specific heat was
a function of temperature and it
multiplied another function of
temperature that would certainly be
nonlinear any examples of materials
whose specific heat depends on
temperature this is beyond my knowledge
I know that there must be some density
definitely does I'm almost sure that
this is true of semiconductors that's
why your computer can only run so fast
and so hot because at a certain
temperature goes into thermal runaway
because this changes pretty sure I'm
guessing I know so that would be
certainly nonlinear what would be the
easiest assumption we could make about
our thin cylindrical piece of metal to
make this equation simpler
seat of X row of X and K of X are
constant this is really important you
need to know the general ugliest form of
an equation because there are lots of
interesting systems where those are not
constant and you do have queues you need
to know where this comes from but for
example when you're on your qualifying
exams or your added job and you need to
figure out how to actually model a real
solid or a real physical system it's
extremely important to be able to make
the right assumptions that don't
invalidate your model but also make your
physical system much simpler ok so the
one that you named is exactly the one I
would have picked so we're going to
assume that C of X Rho of X and K of X
are constant and that would be a pretty
easy assumption as long as I just assume
that this is made of one material ok
it's a steel rod nothing fancy so if
that happens then these are just numbers
K is just a number and what I get let's
also assume that Q is equal to 0 this
thing's not on fire nothing crazy is
happening it's just you know a regular
piece of metal then we have a relatively
simple equation UT equals some constant
K divided by C Rho times u xx ok now
these numbers are all positive so this
is just a positive number in fact I'm
gonna write it the way we had it on
Wednesday it's just some positive number
times u xx I'm making this alpha squared
to guarantee that it's positive no
matter what okay so this is important
this is our simple absolutely linear
heat equation and this applies to a
incredible range of physical system this
is actually really really really really
useful these assumptions are fairly good
this is the 1d heat equation so it
really only applies to one
he transfer but we're gonna generalize
this to 2d on Monday or in the homework
I haven't decided I almost want to do it
in the homework because the way that you
generalize this heat equation to do 2d
is using all of the great vector
calculus that we learned at the end of
last quarter so remember when we derived
the continuity equation using Gauss's
divergence theorem it's the exact same
story here you take those heat fluxes
and you write them as integrals and then
you use your integral formulas and you
take the limit as those volumes become
arbitrarily small and you recover the 2d
heat equation so maybe I will have it on
the homework I owe you a homework okay
and there's two more things that are
important okay so the equations describe
the physics right so the equation
describes the physics and it describes
it mathematically but that's not all
that we need to solve a problem okay we
need more information okay so what extra
information do we need to actually solve
a real physical problem we certainly
need to know the initial condition right
this thing could have started with any
temperature distribution so we need to
know initial conditions
okay the initial conditions are usually
something like you at all locations and
X at my initial time zero is some
function initial means initial in time
so at time zero what is my temperature
and we also need to know the boundary
conditions so I've already told you most
of the boundary conditions which is that
this thing is insulating on the outside
but I haven't told you what happens at
the end camps
okay maybe their bare metal on the ends
we also need to know boundary conditions
okay
and there's a few types of boundary
conditions so I'm just gonna say
generally this means what happens at x
equals zero and x equals L okay okay and
we're gonna find out kind of very
carefully later that this is enough it's
sufficient and necessary to have all of
this information to solve the entire
problem solving the problem means I want
to know what is my function my
temperature at all points in space at
all points in time that's the solution
okay so what are some common boundary
conditions the initial condition is
pretty straightforward I have an initial
temperature distribution I tell it to
you you know it but there are different
boundary conditions depending on what
the system physics are so what are some
common boundary conditions
periodic I could take this rod and I
could bend it into a circle if I was
really strong and touched the ends
together and make it into a circular rod
so periodic good that will definitely be
either on a homework or on an exam or on
a qualifying exam you'll see it sometime
you won't know when but you'll know when
you see it what are some other good
boundary conditions sorry so let's write
this down this is U of 0 for all time
equals U of L for all time and probably
u x equals it's probably continuous here
also something like that but you really
only need this one okay some other
boundary conditions sorry yeah we could
just hold these at a constant
temperature there's lots of ways to do
it for example if I dump them in you
know water of different temperatures it
has such a fast heat transfer that it in
all for all practical purposes you could
hold this temperature fixed like when
you're boiling a pot of water so that
could be fixed temperature so how would
i code that up in terms of use what does
that mean
so you at point zero at time T is equal
to some constant and you at my other end
at time T is also held constant okay
another super common boundary condition
is insulating right I could put
insulation on the end caps - okay and
what happens if I insulate the boundary
conditions sorry
no heat flux out of the boundaries so so
this would be insulated and no heat flux
we know means that the X derivative is
zero at point zero and outlet the
endcaps there's no flux there's no
partial u partial X so these are some
super common boundary conditions but
there's all kinds of others you could
have mixed boundary conditions where you
have a fixed temperature on one side and
it's insulated on the other if this is
gonna be on the homework I owe you a
homework it will be out today by the end
of the day it will be due next week and
I'm going to make it a little bit
shorter because I'm giving you one week
to do it okay also you probably noticed
that the homework has been a little bit
harder this quarter than last quarter
and the grades have been a little bit
lower but I always grid on a curve and I
expect the exact same distribution so I
wouldn't worry as long as you're you
know within the same relative relative
performance okay there's two last things
I really want to do they're very
interesting so the first thing we're
gonna do is we're going to actually
solve a PDE because we spend a lot of
time thinking about what they could
possibly mean and doing a lot of math
but we should actually solve a partial
differential equation so that we can say
that we've learned something and then
I'm going to tell you how this equation
can get nastier in certain circumstances
it's pretty cool okay so the first thing
that we're going to solve is for an
equilibrium temperature
I guess I'll just erase all of this so
what we're going to do is we're going to
have the same one-dimensional rod and
we're going to essentially try to figure
out what this temperature distribution
looks like at infinite time okay and
we're going to use this equation u T
equals alpha u xx remember alpha is
positive okay if alpha is negative
terrible things happen the universe
implodes so so what we want to solve
this for an equilibrium distribution
okay so what's true in equilibrium for
my heat equation let's hopefully true
heating equals heat out so in
equilibrium that basically means my
temperature is not changing right it's
an equilibrium it's not changing so in
equilibrium u T equals zero this is the
infinite time solution because we hope
that an infinite time this thing reaches
in equilibrium or else things are not
good and so we have Laplace's equation
just UX x equals zero so to solve the
equilibrium temperature distribution we
solve Laplace's equation this is the 1d
form of laplace this is one deal
applause remember that Laplace is like
second partial of U equals zero so in 2d
this would be u xx plus uy y equals 0 in
3d it will be u xx plus UI y plus uz Z
equals 0 and that's also true for the
equilibrium on a two-dimensional surface
or a three-dimensional object you'd
still be solving Laplace's equation
okay now the great thing about Laplace's
equation is that it's so so simple okay
so let's do different boundary
conditions so first we're going to do a
fixed temperature so we're going to have
U at 0 and T equals well there is no T U
of 0 equals a and U of L equals B so
what we're doing is we're fixing
temperature a and temperature beyond the
ends and it doesn't matter what the
initial distribution is I just want to
know what happens after forever okay so
how would I solve this equation I mean
strictly speaking this is no longer even
partial right this is just it's only a
variable a function of X so I would just
integrate this with respect to X twice
ok so what if I integrate both sides
with respect to X what's my left
okay I'm gonna grading this with respect
to X I get you x equals a constant all
right okay constant 1 and let's say I
integrate this again with respect to X
what do I get u equals c1 X plus c2 I
mean there's no tricks it's just that
simple
okay so this is my function U my
temperature is this it's linear a linear
function of X and I all I have to do now
is satisfy my boundary conditions so
let's plug in x equals 0 okay so I have
U of this is U of X so U of 0 just
equals c2 which of course equals a so c2
is a my second constant is just a and I
can do the same thing now I'm going to
plug in L for X so U of L is c1 times L
plus a and what is my temperature at the
right boundary condition beep the
temperature beef so I can solve for my
other constant and I get c1 equals B
minus a divided by health
and so the equation is actually quite
simple I have you as a function of X my
temperature across the entire length is
equal to a plus B minus a divided by L X
and if I was going to draw that what
would that look like for this 1d rod
just a straight line right I have
temperature a and it's going to go up to
temperature B and it doesn't using a
straight line that's the temperature
distribution across the entire rod
SuperDuper simple okay that's the
infinite time equilibrium temperature
distribution if I have fixed
temperatures on the outside okay soon
we're going to do this in two dimensions
we're gonna have a square plate and
we're gonna do the same thing we're
gonna we're gonna have a square plate
and we're going to specify a temperature
distribution a B C and D and we're going
to try to figure out what the
temperature on this plate would look
like if you held this temperature
constant on the boundaries and we'll
plot this up in MATLAB this is a little
boring to plot in MATLAB this one will
be more interesting okay should we do
this for the insulated boundary
conditions yeah okay good so the basic
idea doesn't change at all you still
have you still have this equation this
is true whether or not your boundary
conditions are insulated fixed
temperature or mixed this just comes
from Laplace's equation so now we have
what is it view of x equals c1 X plus c2
and so I'm going to take the partial
with respect to X and I just get c1 and
what it is my UC sorry what am i
insulated boundary condition this to
have for us
equal to zero so c1 equals zero because
I have to have my I have to have my
partial of U with respect to X equal to
zero on the boundaries which means it
has to be zero everywhere and therefore
UX is just a constant this was even
easier okay so we have our rod now the
solution for insulated boundary
conditions if I just have you know
insulation styrofoam around this whole
thing the infinite time solution is a
constant temperature all the temperature
at all points X are equal to each other
makes sense right if I had you know some
steel rod and I had some initial
temperature distribution eventually it's
all going to average out to one
temperature and if I don't let any heat
enter or leave I'm going to keep that
uniform temperature distribution in the
bar I mean that's basically what happens
if I had a steel bar sitting on the
table all of lecture it would be one
temperature right no matter even if I
held it on one end walking in and it was
warmer on one end so what is this
constant temperature equal it's not
arbitrary c2 is not arbitrary
what does c2 equal
well it equals the average temperature
distribution from my initial condition
which I didn't tell you so there's some
initial condition right and c2 is my
average temperature from my initial
condition so c2 equals one over the
length times the integral from zero to L
of U of X at time zero D X interestingly
this would be true at all time this
would be true at time one at time two at
time three four five six so you could
actually drive everything just from this
conservation law which is kind of neat
okay there's a lot more we're gonna be
essentially essentially what we've just
done is we've solved the equilibrium
solution where there's no change in
temperature over time so that was a huge
assumption we solved this in 1d so the
next couple of things we're going to do
is we're going to learn how to write the
heat equation in 2d and 3d we're going
to learn how to solve Laplace's equation
in 2d and 3d and then we're going to
learn how to solve the heat equation for
the transients I want to know how I go
from this initial temperature
distribution how it goes to this one
like what happens in time as it goes to
equilibrium because that actually is
really important so we don't know what
happens in the middle here and that's
one of the the major things we're going
to learn next week and let me see okay I
have like one minute left and I do want
to tell you something I'll tell you next
time so think about what this would look
like if I relax the condition that this
bar was insulated so imagine that I'm
sitting in a fluid bath and I have a
constant temperature on the outside and
the steel bar has its own temperature
distribution how would this equation
change if I could allow heat flux out
into the universe
how many of you heard of blackbody
radiation ok blackbody radiation is a
quartic a fourth order nonlinear term
for Q we'll talk about this later it's
the reason quantum mechanics was
discovered in the first place was
because writing this down caused people
to realize that we would have infinite
heat energy generation in the universe
if energy wasn't quantized it's called
the ultraviolet catastrophe so we'll
talk a little bit about how this Q could
be interesting next lecture on Monday
all right have a great weekend thank you
you